great whites grow up to 20 feet long
and can pack over 5 000 pounds of muscle
yet despite their size
they often go unnoticed
a type of camouflage known as counter
shading gives these sharks the predatory
edge
they're dark on top but pale underneath
so underwater
they blend into the background
whether seen from above
or below
[Music]
but all that changes
from the air
all right here we go tether joan
taking off
from high in the sky
a shark's camouflage can't hide them
and their cover will be blown
let's try to find some sharks here
[Music]
the best view of what's below the
surface
comes from high above
andy's drone scans from the sky
and while down at water level
it looks like every other day at the
beach
the view from above
whoa right there
reveals a very different story
a drone's eye view
detects an unmistakable silhouette
now you see it
now you don't
it's pretty incredible
there's sharks everywhere
literally right under the boards of
these people
right under their noses and they don't
even see it
down at water level
glare and reflections can easily
distract
hiding what looks obvious from high
above
[Applause]
i got a lot of sharks in the area this
is incredible
it looks too close for comfort
but are people in danger
despite santa barbara's increase in
shark sightings
there hasn't been a fatal shark bite
here
in almost a decade
a stat that today's survey will help
unpack
synchronized watches
all right great white stakeout here we
go
all right and three two one here we go
[Music]
you